nimmt sie panisch drogen khedira wird
von einem akku
[Musik]
bereits viele fitness wettkampf gut
der erfolg fordert aber sie pries die
fitness sucht schwarz steuer und ist nie
zufrieden mit sich selber
die zeit verspielt sie dieses ganze geld
verkrampft methode und steven defour
andrick bank versucht ihnen ins
newsletter
[Musik]
der blog ist gerät oder heimen sp am
morgen ist nicht das größte problem
sondern heroin kokain oder benzodiazepin
es gibt sie zum letzten zug vors
parlament nimmt die harte drogen als
klärt der metallbauer
er möchte struktur ist im lena
leidenheimer sie aber mit seiner
vergangenheit ist es schwierig oder
wochen
[Musik]
demotiviert frankfurt die der grube
weiter
[Musik]
ohne arbeit und tagesstruktur verbringt
reto fast jeden tag und jede tage
verspricht märkte verlangen größer wird
wieder drogen zu konsumieren
[Musik]
regelmässig oder ad klinik seehofers
burgdorf die therapie natur kennt und
doch spürt dass er nie wieder abstürze
und machen mit gedanken was wertete
nutzer für oder sehr frühe und späte job
verhängen
also station beschäftigung bist du dir
viele job bekommt wenn du jetzt daheim
mit unten erweitert und gearbeitet
also wenn das wird zwar immer noch
intensiv gesucht auf facebook backofen
oder über dem schluss gelangen kann
denn ganz anders aus
wenn jetzt aus gut und ich jetzt mal
hoffen
[Musik]
es gab beschäftigungsprogramm für lüthi
die situation wieder retour möchte
richtige job unter drogen entscheidend
entweder zunächst die absturz
die 25-jährige ist sechs mal in der
woche zwei stunden fitness dass ich für
sie drei funktionen
damit ist schwierig einfach mit wie sich
vielleicht einmal will ich würde selbst
ich bin dann weiß ich schimpfe sein dass
mir eigentlich noch ist alles offen ich
also vermutlich standing eigentlich
schon sehr wichtig
es geht um disziplin um kontrolle rang
zwei
[Musik]
tamedia will ihre körperbeherrschung und
sie strahlen mit sich
instagram jasmunder vor ihrem körper
viele frauen träumen
und trotzdem ist nicht so dass ich
einmal wahlkampf gemacht haben natürlich
spielt haben das schon mal weismachen
anders und hält gut fünfzehn bis zwanzig
kilo schwer und
spitzensport kurz oder lang zu der
samina ihrem leben schon als achtjährige
gott sie ist grundstücken trainiert
viermal pro woche als teenager fazit
fitness mit erfolg mit 220 ist samira
miss bikini schweizer meisterin im
fitness und holten vierter platz oder
weltmeisterschaften
samira der körper im griff ist strikt
nach plan
nach der wettkampf krebs ist gegenteil
sie regelmäßig verbesserten struktur ein
teufelskreis mitglied samira andere
schweres stück
sie wirkt alles ab und kontrolliert
krankhaft was ist und was nicht
[Applaus]
es macht wenn sie allein den 40
kontrolle
ich bin dann aus schulden acht
tankstellen oder zum selecta automaten
messer geholt
ja das ist natürlich wie ein ruhig also
man muss sich das vorstellen konnte
[Gelächter]
endlich vor wenn man es halt so
von mira sucht regelmäßig einen
therapeuten sieht das budget ist sie
aber 100% krankgeschrieben
bei der zählstelle als hochbahn
zeichnerin verloren
der technik und des sports habe
beruflich und privat die sache wo
angefangen hat
in brück um mich aus der bahn gehört hat
und mit psychischer zustand hat sich
dann halt extrem verschlechtert er
glaubt dass schlafstörungen
[Musik]
mit dem formular woods am etat ihres
lebe jetzt von grund auf andere ins
parkdeck gott sich für mehrere monate in
kliniken tor hütete reto via
internettelefon auf erzählt wie's geht
mehr sport machen
als ich sagte meine kinder so ist genau
dies sollte probiere doch mit trink- und
möglichst nur vermietung
es braucht später darauf vom ritus blieb
trotzdem gute vorsätze hätte der kampf
gegen drogen ein schmied verloren
[Musik]
das ist nicht viel
der tod sofort reagiert und sich für
eine stationäre aufenthalt in der klinik
gemeldet
jetzt muss er warten bis klar warum das
ist es verschreibungspflichtiges
medikament wo zum beispiel depressionen
oder zu dick war groß eingesetzt wird
die wirkstoff benzodiazepin nachtschlaf
rick entspannt und schnell süchtig
normalerweise nimmt mit storm ii chrome
als tablette schmale nase würde es aber
schneller und heftiger und
[Musik]
die dosis wieder reto sie nimmt würde
die meisten flächen wieder in
einigermaßen funktioniere noch
[Musik]
was bedeutet es not tut
natürlich natur und natur bleibt und
nicht mal so wie wichtig ist das wort zu
sagen sie denen oder eto'o l fixies hat
sie vorab super und ich rutschte aber
gestorben
[Musik]
note 3 buchholz bis dato handlichkeit
klinik bis dann muss in versuchten
irgendwie alltag bewältigen
[Musik]
das historische 46 und türkisch
schweizerische doppelbürger die zeit
montiert stadt für ihm eine 1 zimmer
studio er ist viel allein ältere und
tipps machen den untergrund derzeit ist
spielsüchtig und hec vertrauen für
seinen verwandten immer wieder
missbraucht kollege anzug sie 15 jahre
ist spielsüchtig arbeitslos und einsam
sehnsucht hätten als genug finanzielle
sozialhilfe abhängig und verteilt vor
der ältere r kämpft mit depressionen
trotz der situation spielten immer
wieder runter der casinos gesperrt ist
vor allem mit sportwetter via handy
wie sie in hersteller sportvereine ich
bin auf einer weißen provisionen 222
verbrauchsarme tippt und es ist 22 und
das heißt das nicht wenig
das spiel ist es schwer
[Musik]
regelmäßige steht jede landstraße zur
spezies der heime aber hier kommen
überall dort verspielen
[Musik]
franken
war eine mode macht ja gewöhnt und
reparatur sequenzen die nächsten
turniere einfach anders
ein kiosk war legal und illegal online
games spielen mit ihnen gar mit kamera
budget zu sieben eigenen schutz nehmen
dieses problem hätten jetzt hat der
kleine gärten lang hatten wir danach
besser morgen bis 4000 franken venice -
kranke wirklich versucht sie damals
unterschätzt aber wirklich für büro aber
drei jahre ist die logik überall und
trotzdem back for good
[Musik]
so bin ich aufgewachsen
an dieser säule dass kollege kreis und
familie vor allem sind die live streams
statt
[Musik]
samir ablichten klinik besser
beziehungsweise die ganze letzte woche
ich finde ich recht schwierig sie mich
mit dem ganzen abzuwenden quasi aber ich
habe einfach versucht das ganze also ich
erhoffe mir oder wünsche mir dass ich
eigentlich werde selber finden kann und
wieder lernen slowakische uni michigan
wir zu fühlen
[Musik]
zwei bis drei monate klinik blieben
frauen agieren stört die behandlung
trotzdem nimmt sie ihre seite der asse
mit klinik bormuth erlinsbach in spezial
klinik für psychosomatische medizin und
psychotherapie der heime für die nächste
minute
das war neues inventar glocke wenn sie
bis heute treffen sich dann alle den
handys eingebaut aber hatten ja schon
ziemlich klasse 5a von rund 445 wenn sie
13 ist ja gut
also mussten wir dafür jetzt auf der
station
sie wählt jeden tag zwischen drüben das
für sie okay schweinefleisch nicht zum
springen wie schön sie das wird diesmal
lasse und denn die - dennoch liebe dass
sie kein schweinefleisch sanierung ihres
asphalt das hört sich andere zusammen
mit ihrer therapeutin der situation dass
sie sich in der hand für ihre stadt in
ihrer jugend hat können sie das problem
benennen was ist der grund sie ist für
ihre kritik geht so sehr sich ich habe
einfach gemerkt dass es für mich ein
normaler alltag und besorgnisse wenig
vielleicht monarchen und ich kann
einfach auch möchte aber dass ich meinen
selbstwert extrem vor dem training
abhängig gemacht haben dass ich mich
schlecht gefühlt haben wenn ich nicht
trainiert haben
und das hat so ein titel kreis mit
schlafstörungen und training
wer schlecht schläft richtig trainieren
werden dann habe ich wieder gasse habe
ich wieder schlapp gefühlt haben wir das
training und das ist habe ich bin
eigentlich immer wie tief das gefühl
kann ja das grund werde das leipzig
werden und irgendein ist denn wenn ich
nur einem prozent geschafft habe ich das
einfach alles sehr diszipliniert um das
ihr leistungsfähig orientiert sich immer
man nicht und das ist eigentlich habe
ich den klassiker sagen dass generell
spitzensportler dass die reben sie
schnell oder nicht schnell aber dass
psychische störung gerät eigentlich das
stück vorderster stelle steht und das
ist die selbe meistens bieten sport will
jede natürlich ein athletischer
körperbau hand und denner ist ein
schönes stück entwickelt sich
kontinuierlich
wo ist dein name diene als attacke endet
geht sowieso sie würde sagen das darf
nicht passieren den stationären
aufenthalt
also für mich weil natürlich ganz schön
wenn ich jetzt gar kein sport mehr
machen aber ich möchte nicht dass es so
wichtig ist dass ich mich jetzt von dem
abhängig nach aber gleich weil es für
mich ging also jetzt gerade zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt schlimm wenn ich jetzt die
rund fünf bis zwei kilo schwer oder
vielleicht das einzige besucht
[Musik]
ist image los
eltville es ist aber endlich griffige
absolut therapie
jetzt hat 15 jahre habe ich viel zu viel
verloren nicht nur geld auch wenige
spiele so schlecht ist der platz neben
kollegenkreis bin ich weiß dass familien
nur wenig entfernt ist dass krieg nein
sie es noch schulden erwähnt noch nicht
versuchen schulden machen sie es nicht
es ist wichtig dass jetzt der teil der
therapie kommt wo wir wirklich konkret
tagesstruktur konkret partnersuche
konkret arbeitssuche wir können das
alles besprechen also sie haben
motivation da rauszukommen
und es ist nicht zu spät
also dann beginnen wir mit der linken
seite linke anspannen forcieren und
jetzt können sie entspannen
eine entspannungsübung ist der herr
stich liegt
mit frischem wind wurde jetzt vorwärts
machen
erster schritt jobsuche er schafft zwar
ab und zu als pizza kurier mit hilfe der
sozial die endstufe jetzt aber die story
of pop das muster machen dass jobsuche
alles laufe aber zeugnisse
zusammenbringen und bei walsleben
[Musik]
whistler
ganz so lange hin
[Musik]
ohne job ist ja langweilig so natürlich
so bizarre wichtiger von moscheen statt
mit uns los ja doch
[Musik]
zwei stunden ist schon fertig
jetzt nächste woche nun mal an ist
termin und mittlerweile geschrieben wenn
ich so in saratoga seven victoria
nur als paar tage später häufig schon
wieder verflogen
die krise vergangenheit vor des
politischen unter cannabis autofahrer
und verwünscht wurde
jetzt ist es los aber zentrum bestimmt
jetzt folgt das ohne auto als pizza
kurier schaffe tanja markloff
pizzakurier gemacht dass es in
beschäftigung sind möglich und jetzt
kommen weitere dazu und ohne
führerausweis platzt die nächste zeit
aussieht rein vom chauffeur
reto heute endlich die klinik das war
ein teamsprecher
[Musik]
wenn dreht sportklinik gott ist das gar
nicht gut für die sieben zustand war das
eine katastrophe
dazu hund tretow wurde noch unbedingt
erlebt die dosis dormicum nitrit aber
wenn es gut konzert das ja eigentlich
die letzte dort nehme ich habe die dinge
er soll sie geben die geben dass das die
letzte ton kontinent nein ich kann jetzt
im klinikum genau vor zwei oder drei
sätzen
paradox dies sehen auch sondern da ich
ja selbst
[Applaus]
es ist schließlich irgendwo tätig sein
dran
[Musik]
das nächste mal mit letzter kraft die
klinik zurück kampf verfolgt aber wieder
ziehen spielsucht
eltern übers nächste stunde hatte das
gelb mühlacker und sammler krampf die
die klinik mit verschiedenen problemen
vormittag ein etwas unter der woche
haben und will was ich finde es ist
[Musik]